good evening my name is Lukas and I'm a
senior pre-med student from Phoenix
Arizona and it is my pleasure to
introduce your speaker for tonight
Victor Davis Hanson Dewayne and Marcia
bused
distinguished fellow in history at
Hillsdale College is also a senior
fellow at the Hoover Institution and a
professor of classics at an oppressed
professor of classics emeritus at
California State University Fresno he
earned his BA at the University of
California Santa Cruz and his PhD in
classics from Stanford University in
2007 he was awarded the National
Humanities medal and in 2008 he received
the Bradley prize from Lynde and Harry
Bradley Foundation he has written for
numerous publications including the
Claremont Review of Books the New
Criterion and The Wall Street Journal
he is the author of several books
including a war fought a war like no
other how the Athenians and Spartans
fought the Peloponnesian War the second
and the second world wars how the how
the first global global conflict was
fought and won would you all please
welcome me and joining Victor Davis
Hanson to the stage
thank you very much when doctor aren't
mentioned stitches in the face I get a
lot of emails from people who say I
think you need some work on your face
and I said I've already had it but al
Phillip and I were supposed to go on a
trip seven days later so I had a
concussion the spinal injury and I had
170 stitches and I asked al how much
money we would lose if with all the
cancellations so suddenly I got cured
and I wanted to tell Larry when he
mentioned all of these disasters I
thought I hope Hillsdale is not the
common denominator but it hasn't been
for me it's been a wonderful experience
15 years coming here I'd like to talk
just about 35 minutes not just about
George Patton in the tragic view but our
strange and ambiguous relationship in
the United States between generals and
politics you know we've had 12
presidents that were generals
but none of us really know any of them
and who cares whether Chester a Arthur
was a general we remember the Harrison
and his grandson or peers or Taylor but
most of the generals we don't Andrew
Johnson who cares that he was a brevet
Brigadier General we have four that
became presidents with the exception of
Jackson they were pretty much a
political by that I mean Grant was a
unionist more than he was a radical
republican and I think both Democrats
and Republicans approached Eisenhower
and no one was quite sure what side he
was on in Washington of course was the
father of our country but we have had if
we haven't had over and we have by the
way we had three generals remember
working for Donald Trump at one time
general Kelley the chief of staff
general mattis Secretary of Defense
and HR McMaster the lieutenant-general
was a national security device I have a
feeling two out of the three of them
either didn't vote for Trump or won't
vote for it next time so I guess they're
called bipartisan or apolitical but we
have had ideological generals I don't
know if ideology is the right word for
it but we've had generals who connected
what they did on the battlefield with a
larger view of human nature and I guess
we would call it the tragic or
pessimistic view that we are born into
this world pretty despicable or evil and
religion and culture and civilizations
save us but it doesn't always reach
everybody and there's always going to be
people who want to take things that are
not theirs whether in the personal or
national level or their psychopathic and
they like to kill people and it's the
duty of certain people among us this
view I think some generals have that
they have certain talents and they spot
these people and they're willing to do
what it takes to protect the innocent
from them and out of that ideology they
also develop a conservative a
reactionary political view and you think
of MacArthur but in our own history
think of William Tecumseh Sherman Curtis
LeMay and you know Matthew Ridgway and
they don't end up well I mean they have
a dark view of human nature and we're a
therapeutic sunny society an upbeat
Society and when we're done with them
we're done with them they provide a
useful service Sherman said I will not
run for office if nominated I will not
accept the nomination if elected I will
not enter the presidency and people
thought to this day that he was a
barnburner that he was a tear I see the
word terrorist and Sherman Sherman had a
philosophical view a tragic view that
they were in an existential war and a
lot of innocent people were getting
killed and the people who had
precipitated that war he called him the
shovel shovel ear class in the south
should not function with impunity at
home and so when he went to Atlanta and
the March the see in the March the
Carolina's if you actually do the
terrible arithmetic of how many people
he killed visa vie that summer of the
Army of the Potomac with grant locked
with Lee there were far fewer dead but
he did something that was unspeakable
he destroyed property and humiliated an
entire class and he developed an
ideology and explication of what he was
doing and why they deserved it and now
that was intolerable and to this day
when grant can have can have been
responsible for some of the most bloody
battles in the history of American wars
but Sherman has an asterisk next to his
name the same is true of another general
and we all love how Arnold we hear of
Tooey Spaatz Doolittle but when we say
Curtis LeMay we stop some of you think
the cigar
we don't ever hear that he had Bell's
palsy on a record flight set the
distance record 1937 and a b-17 on the
wait in the flight he got Bell palsy
stuck a cigar there to stop the drill
absorb the dripping of saliva so it
wasn't some Hollywood gimmick to be
tough it was a way of trying to disguise
a disfiguring ailment but he ended up
after the war remember as the model of
Buck Turgeon s'en and dr. Strangelove
and then during the Cuban Missile Crisis
people caricatured him because he wanted
to be pretty tough for the Soviet Union
and he ended up running tragically with
George Wallace as his vice president
candidate third party American
independent party 1968 we forget that he
actually tried to convince Wallace not
to run on a segregationist or racist
ticket and he was one of the first green
candidates we've ever had but we had
this image that LeMay said that it would
be inhuman for a million people to die
invading the mainland of Japan and he
could do it through bombing and he
inherited the b-29 billion-dollar probe
to billion dollar bigger than the
Manhattan Project and they had no
results from China nd India or from the
Marianas and he took this wonderful high
precision high-altitude bomber
that could fly up to 28,000 feet and he
took it down to 5,000 feet and he
basically created a four-engine dive
bomber and filled it with 20,000 pounds
of napalm and in 90 days burned down 65%
of the urban industrial area of Japan
and he was adamantly opposed to the 509
composite bombing group because he
didn't think the atomic bomb was
necessary in other words he thought that
he could as he said lender Japan pre
into a pre-modern state had the war gone
on he had plans to use for airfields
from okinawa and to bring remember the
war in Europe had ended in May and there
were 10,000 for engine be 24 and b-17
and Lancaster bombers that were idle
another 8,000 to engine bombers be
26,000 b25 he was going to aggregate
them with 2,500 b-29s in the Marianas
triple the mission capacity because
Okinawa was 1/3 of the distance and
finished off the rest of the Japanese
industrial sector it's pretty
nightmarish scenario but the idea that
he was behind all that and remember he
said if the we lose a war I'll be tried
as a war criminal was that we're not
going to send people who had nothing to
do with this war from Nebraska and
Missouri and invade the mainland when
people who are actively killing 15
million people in China are going to
escape a rendezvous with judgment that's
what he said Matthew Ridgway inherited
in late December of 1950 a losing Korea
what Korean War remember the Chinese
across the Yalu we had gone up in
November MacArthur had and general
Walton Walker as you go north you know
the peninsula widens in November the
weather worsens and the proximity to
China decreases and the f80 was not able
to provide air support against a MIG 15
for b-29
so essentially we sent a hundred and
fifty thousand people farther and
farther from their supplies and closer
to a million Chinese soldiers and we
didn't have adequate air cover in the
height of winter and when they broke
across it's the longest military retreat
in US history and MacArthur was relieved
and Ridgeway who had never been to Asia
he was an expert in Central America and
of course he was commander of the 82nd
airborne he created basically the 82nd
airborne World War two we fifty years
old he parachuted into Normandy
distinguished record in World War two I
suggest that if any of you have heart
trouble don't despair he had a heart
attack and was told he had to be
decommissioned and go back into civilian
service at 54 at the end of the war and
he lived to be 98 so don't despair but
in any case he wore a little medical kit
here and a hand grenade here it called
him old iron tits and he walked the
battlefield he said find him fix them
and kill them and he said don't despair
we're gonna take Seoul back they took
Seoul back by March the b-29 napalm and
artillery killed as we heard today quite
correctly killed about a million Chinese
one reason that China did not want to
invade in Vietnam and is because of the
terrible losses that they hid from
historians and the West that they and
that were incurred by Ridgeway in that
counter-offensive and then Ridgeway got
after basically saving and taking back
so what was the reward for eisenhower
when he wrote his memoirs said that
Matthew Ridgway didn't take sole crusade
in Europe it's it's there he didn't even
get he hated him so much and when
Johnston's
wanted to go with Eisenhower wanted to
go in Vietnam called in Ridgeway said
don't do it you can't win the land war
in Asia Johnson went into Vietnam and he
thought it's time to get out I'll get
that old Ridgeway he'll give me the same
advice and he said I got to get out
which way she just can't get out he said
why can't I get out he said there's only
one thing worse than losing him
only one thing worse than getting into a
bad war and that's losing it
so he gave people advice and he talked
in a certain manner he's married three
times which is a no-no at that time in
the top echelon of the American general
and he didn't end up well he didn't get
the type of credit that he should in the
way that LeMay didn't in a way that
Sherman did which all brings us to
George Patton I wish I could say that he
was a superb he had superb character he
did in many ways but I think in many
ways he was trumpian if I couldn't and
that's not meant as a criticism
gratuitously by that I mean he could be
gratuitously cruel to people he as you
know slapped two soldiers and Sicily one
of which one of whom probably had
malaria we know it had a high
temperature
he was resented by most of his peers
because he was from one of the
wealthiest families in America Mount
Wilson in LA that was his grandmother
whilst the Wilson family his father was
the City Attorney of LA and owned a
thousand acres in Pasadena
he was fabulously rich on his own family
side and then he married in to the air
pharmaceutical company fedebook errors
big Empire so when the image of American
officers was Omar Bradley an Eisenhower
and Lucien Truscott
and Wade Haslip all of these great
people from the hinterland of America
here came Patton from California playing
polo with his own yacht and a stable of
horses all during the Depression and he
had been in the 1912 Olympics he came in
fourth he might have won the panathlon
he claimed that he was such a good shot
that each time he shot he put the bullet
right through the prior hole and the
judges didn't understand that
and he may have been right but if you
follow his career through the 20s and
30s up until Pearl Harbor it was
characterized by absolute brilliance he
was the first person to see that the
Christie tank in 1919 had the bestest
suspension and the Americans should go
for it and yet we didn't do it and that
was the model that the t-34 Russian tank
adopted he under he designed the u.s.
Calvary's saber he'd also designed it
the first u.s. tanks who they called it
the you know I think it was called the
Green Arrow or the Green Lantern it was
kind of silly I had a gold helmet and
green pads and gaudy boots but it was
built to be comfortable at jumpsuit he
and in this entire process he learned or
I shouldn't say he learned he developed
u.s. armor tactics 1940 in wargames in
Louisiana he captured the senior general
you drum you you may have seen the dirty
doesn't that movie that old movie about
captured of how they played dirty that
was basically based on Patton's war
maneuvers well how he went on a 400 mile
goose chase they thought and ended up
capturing the red general he was on the
blue team and he did that two times then
he went down and got into Indio out of
the middle nowhere and set up an entire
desert warfare complex and taught
Americans with inferior tanks chat like
Chaffee tanks or inferior Lee tanks the
elements of armored pursuit and break
throughs the point I'm making is that
when pearl and he he was 55 and he was
still not a brigadier general people
hated him because he was drank too much
there were periods in his life when he
womanized he played polo as I said he
was accident-prone he lit a gas lamp to
look at his eye and it blew up and
burned his face he accidentally stabbed
himself he would
he broke he in a horse accident he broke
his leg got phlebitis he was always and
of course he died in a freak accident as
well so he was known as injury-prone
reckless rich ostentatious loud and yet
he spoke French read German and was
highly educated the point I'm getting at
is that he enunciated or he articulated
a world view of war and it was similar
to his contemporaries like LeMay and
Ridgeway and also very sure Mineski was
a big admirer of William Tecumseh
Sherman and he basically said that
democracy's or therapeutic societies and
we don't train people thank God to kill
people but there are people in the world
who do and when they do they need people
like George Patton who's part of and yet
not part of a democracy that understands
the evil mind and can make soldiers for
brief periods of time have the training
and the courage and the fortitude to
stand up to the Hermann Goering division
or focke-wulf 190 pilots are you boats
and that was his principle and then you
would kill these evil people and you
protect the innocent and he said that
and we we don't like people to say that
when Colin Powell said what's your
strategy for the first Gulf War he said
we're going to find the Saddam's army
we're going to cut it off and then we're
going to kill it if people got very
angry why did he have to say kill it at
the end
remember when we killed bag daddy Nancy
Pelosi was bad that Trump said that why
did he kill everybody and then when
Trump said we're gonna get rid of these
monster and these animals m13 she said
they're all God's creatures so it's that
therapeutic alternative is deeply
ingrained and it's very hard for
societies like us to mobilize against
these each these perceived threats
without these types of people so when we
were ready after Pearl Harbor to fight
the obvious choice for our first
engagement was George S Patton he had
just been made right before Pearl Harbor
in October he was promoted to Major
General two-star general and yet when we
had Operation Torch the November 1942
landings in northwest Africa he was not
chosen to lead that the entire project
of torch he was given just the Western
Command 30,000 troops the most
incompetent useless general in American
history Lloyd freightin Hall was an
Eisenhower wrote a report and said he
looks like a general he breathes fire
he's our man I've never been more
impressed he would swagger around he
would pound his fist and he didn't know
anything and the result was as you know
the worst defeat in American history
really was cut or you at least the most
humiliating the Kaiser impasse where
Rommel destroyed an entire Brigade 3,000
missing 400 dead 600 tanks just
frightened halt where was he 50 miles
back dug in and a bunker probably drunk
when it was time to take over second
Corps
everybody thought Patton will get his
chance and yet Eisenhower asked general
Harmon to do it who turned down said
this is pretty embarrassing Patton
deserves it so Patton took over
immediately at the Battle of L guitar
Gazzara he won the first battle
Americans had won in World War two and
he wanted to continue ahead of second
Corps and then Omar Bradley his
had a very strange relationship with
Bradley and the movie was quite I think
I think the was quite quite misleading
about the attitude of Bradley toward
Patten but Bradley then was given
command of second Corps and Patton was
supposed to plan Sicily you would
thought that too many people had died in
North Africa needlessly without giving
patent the main responsibility for the
invasion of Sicily operation husky and
yet we deferred to general Montgomery
they both both the Seventh Army and the
British 1st army landed in southern
Sicily everybody knew what the aim was
it was to get to Messina
two miles from the Italian coast could
cut it off and cut off 400,000 troops
and Patton looked at his assignment it
was to stay to the left or west of
Montgomery and protect his flank and be
stationary basically and give Montgomery
the a chance to speed right to Messina
and then trap the entire Italian and
German of course he knew Monte wouldn't
do that money was a great general and a
set-piece but he was not a pursuer he
didn't pursue so what at Patton do he
went all the way to Northwest to Pilar
Merle then made another right turn broke
orders and got to Messina before
Montgomery and of course didn't what
didn't get there in time to trap the
Germans but he became very famous after
that you think that at that point
everybody knew that orbital Overlord was
being planned in conjunction with the
Italian invasion that he would get a
supreme command he slapped two soldiers
quite despicably he went into a hospital
he was mad because the absentee rate of
soldiers for what we would call
post-traumatic stress syndrome what was
known then as shell-shocked one officer
had a there were three officers who
watched the first slapping incident the
person had malaria when he was slapped
second one two weeks later he had some
ailment whether it was a fever or was
just stress we don't know but he slapped
him in this period one of his armored
companies was on a bridge there was
an Italian farmer with two mules they
were being strafed they didn't want to
run over the Mules it was very narrow
bridge Patton went out hook took out his
357 on its right on right hand and he
had a 45 colt the other and shot these
two mules and had them thrown over the
bridge and this was considered terrible
think of this therapeutic mindset here
you have a whole column stopped and the
papers and journalists are angry that
Chuck Patton shot two mules and threw
them over the bridge to facilitate the
company getting out of a strafing attack
but in that kit that was a very
important point though because he
obviously should have been given one of
three possible appointments one would
have been overall commander in Italy and
that went to mark Clark who we know
mostly from falling for the German
gambit where Germany basically the
German forces under Kesling have
basically allowed us to take Rome as a
way to escape an encirclement and they
knew that Mark Clark of all journals
would want to go into Rome especially
during the d-day operations and get some
glory and then that would give them a
chance to escape the encirclement and
they predicted perfectly Patton wouldn't
have done that on the Anzio earlier in
January that was a very tricky remember
that was a tricky on fibia Sam operation
to land at the main port or near the
main port of Rome people didn't know
whether we could do it surprise we had a
beachhead there were very only one
German battalion there for about 24
hours general John Lucas sat there for
five days until that Germans made an
entire semicircle of heavy artillery and
armored against the Patton would not
have done he was not given either
appointment because he was under
suspicion for slapping two soldiers he
was not saved as is often seen in the
movie and in popular literature by Omar
Bradley who wanted him sent home it was
not saved necessarily by Eisenhower his
letters of support were post facto it
was not even George Marshall was Henry
Stimson Secretary of War who said that
we can
win the war without this man or at least
we can't win it at a cost that we can
afford so then we come to the big
commands decision the planning of the
invasion of Normandy that had been
talked about since 1942 Americans under
Marshall it's told the British we want
to invade nor November of 1942 even they
after they admitted what had happened in
North Africa thought that was a mistake
then we wanted to go in 43 and then
after our problems in Sicily they said
that was wise then we wanted to go in
January at 44 then they said you're
right to the Brits we had trouble in
Italy Patton had said that all along he
was completely shut out of all planning
for Overlord in fact it was adding
insult to injury where he was a command
of a shadowed army what the Germans
called army group Patton where he just
raced around in a car all up and down
from Scotland although that way the
Wales with horn blaring so everybody
thought he was going to invade at Calais
and then for Panzer divisions would be
held in reserve waiting for invasion
Patton which never would come and then
the Panzers would not be released to cut
off the American beachhead so he didn't
participate in Normandy remember after
that brilliant landing we at least it
outside of Omaha Beach
we were ossified calcified for about 40
days we lost more in the next two weeks
and we did in the and the landing and we
eventually had 80,000 casualties before
we broke out of the book cause on July
28th with operation Cobra even then when
Patton's Third Army was operational
Bradley tried to stop the publicity of
the release of news accounts of it I'm
not suggesting that he was mild and
mannered and polite about this he said
things that were absolutely insane I
mean he said Brad just point me in the
right direction and the smokes gonna
you're not gonna even see me when I'm
gonna all be gone all the way to the
Rhine said things like that all the time
but again the point was to take a
civilian conscript group of young men
and make them into an army that could
stand up
people who had been fighting on the
Eastern Front for for years against the
toughest soldiers in the world when you
start to look at some of those German
armored divisions Panzer Lehr division
and you see the type of equipment 88
millimeter Panther and Tiger 1 and 2
tanks it's amazing that we could stand
up to them and that was Patton's I did
so they assigned him the furthest south
position in the advance toward Germany
and that would if you take a map and
draw a line on it it would go into
Czechoslovakia and not Germany that was
by intent but most importantly they
asked him to take breasts which is if
you look at the map of Normandy he would
have to turn around and go the opposite
direction and he was not designated to
go really in the first month east at all
of course you know Patton what he did he
took 1/3 of his army and went north and
he'd said went one west and then he
headed east and in a series of orders
that were overridden he said to General
John Wooden grow take Brest now and they
were a day away and Bradley stopped it
and of course you know what happened
after that
Brest was heavily fortified it took us
about two months we had about 40,000
casualties and the port was never used
until October it's a complete waste of
time when he did go east he soon was
able after the breakout to go about 40
miles a day he went 400 miles by the
middle of the first week in September
when we got to Argentina in the Falaise
pocket there was the entire army group
West 300,000 Germans were advancing
toward the Atlantic while Patton was
coming up to their rear in hopes of
meeting the Canadians and Hitler would
not let von Kluge retreat and it looked
like the war would be over all we had to
do was close the Falaise pocket and Omar
Bradley said you will not do that
because you'll I'd rather have a round
shoulder than a
connect we have to have an escape route
for some of them and Patton said oh hell
I'll meet the Canadians I'll meet the
Brits and the Brits get in my way I'll
push them all the way to dunker well you
can you can't say that and so money will
never close it well it was never closed
for seven days it was heavily bombed ten
thousand Germans were killed most of the
equipment was lost but about a hundred
and fifty five thousand Germans escaped
about ten divisions two of which were
rearm 'red and we dropped Montgomery did
the hundred and first the 82nd and the
first British parachute division right
on top of them basically in the Arnheim
Market Garden so when general modal was
ready defeated us and destroyed Monty's
plan to leapfrog in most of those troops
had been in the Falaise pocket when he
got past Paris he begged to close
another gap or another encirclement on
the eastern side of the Sand River he
was not listened to he said that he had
too few troops and then he headed back
into the Lorraine and on September 2nd
his daily allotment think of this four
hundred thousand gallons of gasoline he
got 15,000 gallons part of it was
because the operation was conceptually
flawed there there was not enough
supplies to get from the beaches three
or four hundred miles into Germany and
support about seven hundred thousand
troops Canadian American and British in
part was that Eisenhower had made I
think a disastrous decision by
redirecting most of the supplies of the
US 3rd and 1st army in the month of
September 1944 to Montgomery to do this
Market Garden bit when he didn't close
the estuaries at the harbors at Harbor
at Antwerp had we got to work nobody
would have had problems with supplies
the net result is Patton stayed 45 days
without fuel and ended up in a world war
one slugfest which wasn't his forte
around Metz and finally when he in March
when he went across the Rhine with the
first army to his
North the rest is pretty much history he
captured about three hundred and fifty
thousand prisoners and was although he
went three hundred miles in two weeks
and that was the end of the war he did
tell eisenhower I can take Berlin and I
said we're not gonna lose three hundred
thousand that's how much we think that
Russians will lose they lost one hundred
and seventy thousand men and he said
something that was very pressing said
they will lose that many but when the
Germans see Americans coming they'll be
all too happy to surrender to us and not
go into gulags or be killed and he was
not allowed to take Berlin and I think
that had repercussions so all of these
decisions that I talked about where I
think he was right had repercussions we
lost an inordinate amount of people in
Italy we never got into Austria the
whole idea of Churchill's
soft underbelly going into Europe or
going through the Ljubljana gap was a
failure
we didn't when the war ended American
troops were still in Italy I don't know
what the purpose of the Sicily campaign
was it was to be a stepping stone into
Italy you go through history all the way
back to Hannibal and no Army has ever
invaded Sicily and gone into northern
invaded Italy and gone into northern
Europe successfully by taking Sicily you
usually have to go to Sardinia or
Corsica and go across or cut off
somebody or go from the north south so
those those entire campaigns I think
were flawed the Normandy campaign would
have been I think we could have said it
could have been over in September 1944
we had we closed the gap or had we tried
to close it again at the same his
greatest moment of course was during the
Battle of the Bulge Patton was finally
given the gasoline he was on the
offensive and von Rundstedt did not call
the von Rundstedt offensive but it was
not really his idea was Hitler's mad
idea that we had two green divisions in
the 1st army and if he took a 250
thousand man salient and broke through
he could separate the Americans from the
British there would not be overall
command
he could go to the Meuse river and then
maybe just maybe go to Antwerp and then
have some type of private deal with the
British or US and say let's just call it
off but he exhausted all of most of the
reserves the problem was if you were one
of fifty thousand US troops in that
pathway and you woke up for ten days
every morning and it was snowy and you
had no air support when 90 percent of
the aircraft in the sky for the last
sixty days had been American or British
and suddenly you were looking at
battle-hardened veterans and they had as
I said tigers and Panthers you're gonna
die or be captured eighty thousand
Americans are Patton saw that happening
and when he went to the meeting with
Eisenhower Verdun he knew what was going
to happen that somebody had to cut off
the salient he had already told his
staff we've got to turn around three
entire divisions I mean that's 45,000
men and turn him in the opposite
direction in 24 hours so it was his
greatest moment it was very theatrical
he went to the meeting and aizen's hell
I don't know how we're gonna stop these
guys they're gonna take over a bus stone
there make it at the moose and he's said
to announce to Bradley and to Montgomery
and to Eisenhower
I can turn three divisions and I can cut
them off he said Georgia will take two
weeks and he said I I'll go out and give
this signal on the phone and they will
start in 24 hours and that's exactly
what they did the tragedy of that is of
course he argued vehemently that the way
to stop a bulge is not to go at a
diagonal and push the nose back it's to
take a chance and cut it off at the base
and allow a few more casualties at the
tip but therefore destroy the entire
invasion of course that was considered
too reckless and we didn't do that and
that battle went all the way into
February and we lost more men after
Bastogne than before what I'm getting at
is that there's a pattern here of
somebody that has undeniable experience
preparation and natural genius who
understands the horrific nature of war
and bothers the people that command him
and yet sequentially our time and time
again
when he is not given a billet or an
appointment or a promotion befitting
what he's earned on the battlefield
people die and yet the way that the
system or the therapeutic society
justifies that is that he slapped a
soldier Germans of course were
bewildered by this I mean it is a little
mythical that Germans knew a pat and I
don't think the movie is quite right
that he was canonized by the Germans
mostly after the war they sort of
changed their views they call him a
cowboy and kind of reckless but the
point I'm making is it is true that a
number of German intelligence officers
wouldn't believe that somebody of his if
his talent would be relieved for
slapping a couple soldiers when German
German officers killed 25,000 soldiers
in World War two shot them for cowardice
or had them ordered shot and so this
brings up finally to conclude I entitled
this talk the tragic nature and I think
Patton is symbolic of a problem that all
Western societies deal with since the
Greeks that the advent of civilization
is a wonderful thing it creates leisure
it creates material wealth luxury it's
civilization it's not tribalism it's not
barbarism but in that process we become
tame and yet the world around us is not
tame and we don't quite know how to
justify using violence against people
who want to kill us this sounds very
contemporarily relevant I think all of
you know in that war against terror and
so from time to time we see these
fossilized memories of our past and we
bring them out of the proverbial closet
and we say help us Curtis will made the
b-29 program doesn't work I know it's
safe for our fliers at 30,000 feet but
there the bombs are going off falling
off talk well you go down on the 5000
with napalm that'll cure it oh my god
you're gonna burn people alive I'll get
rid of the industry or Matthew Ridgway
I'm gonna let them come in and then I'm
gonna surround them with napalm and I'm
gonna blast them and it's going to be
winter and there
they're gonna regret they ever went into
Korea or Sherman this is the plantation
of Howell Cobb this is the guy who said
that
250,000 Confederate soldiers were
superior to us burn his plantation Oh
Mao he burned he burned up southern
plantation and so we when we see
somebody like Patton and they're and you
can see it in our culture throughout our
culture's just not military that was
what made John Ford famous that if
you're Ethan our and Alan Ethan Edwards
excuse me in the searchers and you want
to find a small girl and you're dealing
with some pretty tough Native American
tribes you want somebody with a dubious
past we're not quite told what he was
maybe a Quantrell Raider John Wayne and
he's you don't know whether he's going
to kill Natalie Wood or not but he has
the skills that both ensure that he's
gonna bring her back but as you remember
once she's back he opens the door and
walks out you don't want a guy like that
there any more than you want Gary Cooper
in High Noon to stay around after he's
done what you have to do shoot four
people in the street you don't want the
Magnificent Seven in the village anymore
I remember that famous Yul Brynner and
Steve McQueen said well I guess they're
happy and you said they'll even be
happier when we leave
and I'll just finish by saying that this
is not a new phenomenon that we we
sometimes misdiagnosed talent throughout
all aspects of American society I did
make a promise I just want to interrupt
that I wasn't going to mention the name
Donald Trump that in this talk but you
can see that this person has certain
obnoxious characteristics and certain
skill sets that bring results and you
can guarantee that after we are the
beneficiaries of the results he's not
going to be on PBS and ten years with
ex-presidents shooting the breeze it's
just not going to happen it's gonna be
persona non grata and I'll just finish
by the when pre civilized Greece was
making this transition to the city-state
especially to radical democracy there
were people who saw the same phenomenon
one of the great minds of the Western
literary canon Sophocles in a series he
wrote a hundred and thirteen plays we
have seven extant but in a series of
plays he looked at this archetype of the
oligarchic aristocratic class that we
had all of these anti-democratic skills
and you you needed them it was right in
the middle some of the plays the latter
plays with the Peloponnesian wars I'm
thinking here a Philip tdys Ajax
Antigone but he makes these characters
come out and by every measure of talent
and courage and bravery they they excel
and yet they all end up badly because to
reward them for those key
characteristics would be a referendum on
your own society and I think that's a
dilemma we all have to appreciate not
asking us to change our views but to
every once in a while look in the
corners and when we see dark people
maybe they're not so dark after all
thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Hansen we now have time
for a few questions please make your way
to the microphone if you have a question
dr. Hansen thank you very much excellent
presentation the one element of patent
that I have always wanted to get more
information on is right before his death
he got into more trouble because he
wanted to invade Russia and he wanted to
arm the Germans and the camps and push
all the way to Moscow because he said a
little avoid problems in the future can
you comment on it
well we remember that his I think his
name was
they called him Jeep Sansa his his
regular chauffeur had been transferred
home after the war so he had a new
driver and the new driver wasn't a skill
and the three people who were with the
driver there were Patton and two others
they had superficial injuries so the
fact that he hit that glass partition
was kind of a freak accident and he was
on his way home
the reason that these conspiracy
theories arose was because two things
he'd been relieved by eisenhower for a
phone call he had with Walter Bedell
Smith and in in it he said my god we've
got the people here they're all over
here and the Russians are natural
killers and we went to war supposedly to
free Eastern Europe from the Nazis and
now we're gonna enslave it so when he
said stuff I don't know how serious he
was but that helped get him and then he
said another thing they said you've got
too many Nazis working for you says you
know like Democrats or Republicans when
the Republicans come in they can't get
rid of all the Democrats out of the
civil service how can I get rid of these
guys and he said it in such a way that
was callous so his main argument was
that that Bolshevism communism after the
war would be as X existential of threat
to the United States as Nazi Germany but
he had greater respect for not
admiration but
for Russian military prowess and
capability than Germany because of their
population and industry so he was
terrified of t-34 tanks and the
ruthlessness of the Soviet Army they had
remember lost 11 million soldiers and
nine million civilians 20 million people
and he thought any sir any regime that
could survive that was terrifying so I
don't think that I think he was right in
the diagnosis but America was in no
psychological position in May when we
were still fighting the Japanese and we
were still a nominal ally of Russia and
we were trying to flatter the Russians
so they would we didn't know if the bomb
was going to be work or if it worked it
would bring a surrender and we didn't
believe Millay LeMay could end it
through airpower so we thought we were
going to have to get the Soviet Union to
help us dr. Hansen you talked a bit
about the therapeutic society that we
live in and you gave a few examples and
more recent times about how it seems to
have advanced a bit do you think it
could get to the point
I mean Patton himself you gave many
examples in which he was ridiculed and
attacked do you think it could ever get
to the point where we would turn to
someone like him again well I mean in
the first Gulf War you could see that
Arnold I mean general Schwarzenegger
thought he was going to play that role
you remember nuts worst man I've been
hanging around al Phillip in my Austrian
but there were people in the first Gulf
War in the Second Gulf War that wanted
to play that role but if you look at
both those Wars I mean after the
so-called highway of death it wasn't
really a highway of death as an media
said and then during the so-called
armistice with Saddam we let them have
helicopters they butchered it was a
disaster we didn't have anybody who said
the more the Imperial Guard is given a
reprieve the more innocent people are
going to be killed and when therefore we
have to destroy them we just didn't do
that so it's it's it's getting harder as
a society becomes more leisured and more
materially enriched to find people from
our pre civilized paths because that's
what war is its preset civilized so I
kind of worry about that and I'm we're
all experiencing a war that started in
2001 it's been 19 years in Afghanistan
we're told by this whole array of
experts but all the reasons that we have
I and I supported the initial war but I
think I counted I would an art but once
there were 23 different reasons I was
told we had to be in Afghanistan nobody
said we're gonna win the war and or
there's no substitute for victory so I
don't know what Libya was about I don't
know what the Syria thing was Iraq we
kind of won the war but then we pulled
out so it's hard it's very hard to see
that it's not the generals the generals
are representations of us and there were
people coming out of the depression who
were impoverished they didn't have the
luxury to be therapeutic and so Patton
was the most popular general the reason
he was so successful was he had broad
public support the parents of the
soldier he slapped wrote a letter and
said that I think it was wrong what you
did but boy we're not going to criticize
you you're saving lives I just don't
think that would happen again
so the general today and I think General
Petraeus was a very good general but
it's more of an intellectual with a PhD
rather than a blood and guts type of
person
or I don't think you'll see people like
grant or Sherman again orally not I
think if a general said today the new
just imagine the new theater commander
in CENTCOM went over to Afghanistan he
had a press conference oh I'm gonna win
beat those sons of [ __ ] they say the
Taliban sons of [ __ ] that's too
simplistic so I just don't think it's
going to happen what dr. Anson thank you
for coming yeah question
and I'd also like to say on behalf of my
father who specifically told me to tell
you that he's read just about every word
you've ever written but I specifically
wanted to ask sort of like you talked
about how Patton was clearly you know
strategically sound and a lot of his
thinking and you know like sort of
seeing what was happening on the eastern
front just the brutality of the Nazis is
we got to go in and you know make the
other poor bastard die for his country
so sort of like you talk about is just
feeling you know Democrat democratic
societies get kind of soft is you know
was that so ingrained and sort of the
Allied High Command having to play all
the politics of the reasons of you know
and the fact that he was abrasive you
know all of them yes sir so just all of
why exactly was the fact that he was
clearly strategically sound like putting
away so like was it really just to the
fact that people made he made people a
little uncomfortable because he you know
he acknowledged that we were gonna have
to be violent to win the war well we
know from his own war as I knew it that
he made faces in the mirror a lot of it
was show and the they weren't they
weren't purl they were ivory-handled
Don's he had that weird horn on his Jeep
with the placards polished his helmet
all of that was a an image to show
people that he was you know he'd give
these speeches you know I don't nobody
ever died for their nobody ever won a
war by dying for your country you kill
the SOB not dying and he gave a terrible
speech on it may be effective but it was
frightening when he said
all of you wounded should be very this
was in Boston of all places after all
you should be very happy because you
didn't get killed people get killed
never did any you know he's just trying
to create this image of himself and the
American army as the equivalent on the
battlefield of the Germans and the
Russians and he had a lot of distinct
disadvantages of doing that in a society
and then when he went out of character
at the Lorraine campaign and Metz he
didn't have fuel and he had a as I said
a world war one stagnant objective he
didn't do very well so his idea was the
Americans are growing up they're young
people everybody works on a car Germans
don't Russians don't 1942 everybody knew
how to take a part of Model A or Chevy
they like their frontier means they're
horsemen they like to move so you've got
to adopt those natural tendencies and
they have armor outflanking thrust with
air support forget the flanks circle
around confuse the enemy don't lose a
lot of people bamm-bamm and that's that
was he tried to craft a strategic
doctrine of war that he felt was
compatible with the American character
as far as he could do it I think he did
a pretty good job in comparison to
people that had no idea of this Hodges
had no idea this Mark Clark would never
think like this Bradley would never
think Eisenhower's cheap worry is how I
keep the coalition together he did a
good job but they'd always say you know
when Patton said I can move three
divisions and save best stone and
Eisenhower said careful now Patton your
reputation hasn't been too good lately
he said I think it's pretty good how can
you imagine the supreme commander
telling that to somebody who's just
offered a way to save an entire division
so it was constant and it wore him out
it was constant ankle-biting
bureaucratic deep state and he he
himself was a throwback to a pre
civilized mentality an aristocratic
mentality where he felt that rich people
who were well-educated and knew how to
ride horses and play polo and sail
should be given certain lad
toons and that was an announcement to a
guy who grew up really poor like Omar
Bradley you know thank you for joining
us again on campus dr. Hanson throughout
this series I can't help but wonder how
the same quality seemed to make a person
both famous and infamous I'm curious if
this is perhaps a curse of success or
just a factor of human nature well I
think you're quite correct in your
general observation now I'm quoting the
7th century bc poet hesiod the most
powerful of all human emotions is Envy
what they called Thawne Oz and it's true
that the more successful person that's
what Greek ostracism the Democratic
culture created ostracize somebody not
because he did something wrong because
everybody knows who he is so we don't
like people who do things that we can in
a democratic pluralistic society but I
think in this case we have a sense as a
democratic affluent 21st century as I
think Barack Obama summed it up best the
arc he always uses term the arc of
history is bending and it was always as
if things are getting better better
better and we're gonna get more humane
and UMaine and we're changing human
nation we have more colleges there's
more kids in the Ivy League we've got
all this technology and we're getting
better and better and better and we're
gonna eliminate people like a patent and
I don't think we are getting better I
don't think there's any proof in history
that we all are other than technology
even that is up and down that we're
getting into a moral human nature human
nature and so these people who show us
and remind us of that they're pretty
scary people I think when I broke them
up I won't break my promise when that
person that starts with a tea said
we don't want these animals there the
people in the neighborhood were relieved
but the people who had private estates
or gates were shocked like Nancy Pelosi
who's got a nice wall to state and Napo
so we've created in our own society
people that have I don't want to be too
epic Ettore but they have pretensions
about human nature but they're never
subject to the ramifications of their
own ideology
[Applause]
I'm going to attempt you to break your
your promise because I'm sure you heard
there was a recent report that Rex
Tillerson and general mattis brought
President Trump to the Pentagon to brief
him on to educate him on the importance
of America's alliances and and so forth
and the the report came out that at one
point Trump got so angry that he yelled
at the generals had said you're a bunch
of losers or something to that effect
and you know and lo and behold after he
got in he changed the rules of
engagement and we we beat Isis and so
forth but just warning that's another
example of what you're describing we
have a know that this Hoover Institution
were not allowed to speak publicly about
another senior fellow so I have great
respect for general mattis but in a
larger sense I think what Trump was
trying to say is that he values optics
he's real reality TVs and ratings
remember every time he gets mad at CNN
he doesn't just say that CNN is fake
news he always said low ratings or he
says you have you seen that guy he looks
really bad on TV so in his way of
thinking he's practical and when he look
at Afghanistan it's bad ratings and bad
optics but he's also got a pre
civilizational animal cunning and how
why would you how can you succeed in the
Manhattan real estate market dealing
with crooked unions crooked politician
kook a crooked community
you got one hat you got the the Builders
Union you got al Sharpton you got Bill
DeBlasio how do you deal with all and
build skyscrapers so he has certain
skill sets and those skill sets are not
compatible with administrative whether
it's civilian or military parlance and
the way you solve problems and I guess
the only way we could reconcile that
paradox is that you wouldn't want a
government of trumps or patents or those
types of people but you might want one
or two of them at on occasion when the
system finds itself incapable of doing
things so if you haven't had workers
wages increases in 12 years or you
haven't had three point five percent
unemployment in 50 years or
african-american unemployment 7 years
then maybe people half the country
decided I'm willing to put up with the
president's saying that Jerry naggy
Nadler is a sleaze bag and he and then I
was really struck just as a fillip to
that I was really struck when I hear
people talk that voted for him that
talked about him it reminds me so much
about reading when I was researching a
book on pattern news reports about
pattern because usually you hear well I
really like what he did I just wish he
wouldn't say that I just wish he
wouldn't tweet and they would say things
about pattern is wow I I really like the
idea that he he beat Montgomery to
Messina but why do you have to do that
and the same thing with LeMay why did he
why did he do that and Curtis LeMay
created the Strategic Air Command
essentially he inherited but it was
nothing and when he left it it had
200,000 people
it was the most sophisticated deadly Air
Force in the world and the reward for
that was being charactered by George C
Scott or bucked urgence and both
characters in dr. Strangelove as a mad
nut and he was anything but a nut he's
very sophisticated educated person Omar
Bradley couldn't speak a word of French
he would never know it and he had a very
beautiful cabin with upholstery that he
towed out in the battlefield that was
his personal Patton slept on the ground
Patton walked around made sure everybody
had dry socks so he wouldn't get trench
foot but it didn't fit the image Bradley
was a
but in fact he when people went to on
leave into England and they were from
the first Army Hodges army they would
lie and say they were Third Army because
they thought they would get better dates
from the nurses we have time for one
more question first of all thank you
again dr. Hinson for speaking um you
were talking about patent strategies and
approach to things and how different it
was from pretty much every other General
of World War two what would you say was
the reason for that do you think and he
was schooled VMI like most of our other
leaders were but was there something
like his early days in the military or
do you think that's just how he was as a
person that caused him to approach
things so differently
well his preeminent biographer Carl TST
said he had a number of serious
concussions traumatic wranglin
he used it in the context because there
was a period in his life where he did
some despicable things like date his
Stepney's or it shouldn't say date
having a fair way was married he had a
wonderful wife but there were certain
elements he did believe in reincarnation
and he did believe that the patent
family is for his grandfather was killed
in civil war so he he had this idea that
he had a destiny and he kept saying I'm
not going to be cheated out of my
destiny and he went into a severe
depression when he was not allowed to
fight in the Pacific so he had this idea
that he was exceptional in his knowledge
of war and he would say again and again
when they talked about closing the
Falaise gap or taking Palermo and then
making a right turn or having an affair
but he'd always say to his staff I don't
know where I got this idea I woke up at
2:00 in the morning with this idea and
yeah and I wrote it down and then he
would give meticulous diagrams of which
particular battalions brigades he would
move and so he believed at least he had
some kind of artistic inspiration about
war I think that's why I think it was
destined aimed his patent a genius for
war there was something about him
mystical and the movie tried to bring
that out maybe exaggerated but people
around him thought that he was not
stable mentally and he would go fly off
into he was completely unaware of the
effect sometimes he had on people who
had control over his destiny so if he
was on maneuvers and right in front of
Eisenhower and Bradley he went over and
screamed at a lieutenant-colonel said
that you son of a bang you did this you
you're gonna get men killed you're not
and then he walked by and smile back and
thinking that Eisenhower was impressed
and Eisenhower later would say this guy
is not fit for high command so
he was soui generous it's-it's we
haven't seen anybody we saw a Sherman
like him and I think there were elements
like him as we heard today in MacArthur
MacArthur had sort of the same some of
the same traits although it's much more
institutionalized than patent and much
more politically savvy I think at least
sometimes is that it then or one more
thank you dr. Hanson
[Applause]